كشف مصدر حكومي مصدر حكومي لبناني للجزيره
ان مفاوض مفوض السياسات الخارجيه بالاتحاد
الاوروبي جوزيب بوريل التقى خلال زيارته
الى لبنان وفدا من حزب الله برئاسه النائب
محمد رعد مشيرا الى ان حزب الله ابلغ
بوريل بعدم امكانيه بحث الملف اللبناني
وتطورات الجنوب قبل وقف حرب
غزه عن هذا اللقاء وعن التطورات الميدانيه
نستقبل ضيفنا من بيروت توفيق شومان الكاتب
والمحلل السياسي سيد توفيق لقاء لافت بين
وفد من حزب الله وبين المسؤول الاوروبي في
وقت ايضا ميدانيا هناك تطورات لافته وغير
مسبوقه حزب الله يقصف اهداف ايضا
استراتيجيه لاول مره كالذي تم هذا اليوم
وايضا اسرائيل تقصف مناطق في الداخل
اللبناني ايضا جغرافيا لاول مره منذ العام
2006 ماذا عن هذين المعطي سياسيا
وميدانيا بالنسبه للشق الاول من السؤال لم
يصدر عن حزب الله لغايه الان اي بيان يوضح
هذا الامر لكن المعلومات السائده في بيروت
عن هذا الاجتماع لكن اعتقد بان هناك
معادله اساسيه كان رسمها السييد حسن الصال
الامين العام للحزب في خطابيه السابقين
وبالتحديد في خطابه الاخير يوم الجمعه
يعني يوم امس بان اي تفاوض مع لبنان اي حل
سياسي حتى بما له علاقه بمهمه المبعوث
الامريكي هوك شتاين لا يمكن الحديث عن ذلك
الا بعد وقف العدوان الاسرائيلي على قطاع
غزه واعتقد بان مثل هذا الكلام جوبه بها
المبعوث الاوروبي في اجتماعه مع قياديين
من حزب الله هذه معادله اعتقد بانها اصبحت
مفهومه وتم ابلاغها رسميا على الاقل كما
يتم تداوله في الاروقه السياسيه اللبنانيه
وكما كشف العديد من وسائل الاعلام في
لبنان لكن لغايه الان لا يوجد بيان رسمي
من الحزب بما يتعلق بال بالوقائع
الميدانيه طبعا هذه لاول مره يتم قصف فيها
هذا الموقع الاستراتيجي واعتقد بان بيان
المقاومه كان دقيقا في شرحه لمهمه هذا
الموقع من ناحيه المراقبه الجويه في سوريا
لبنان تركيا وشمال حو البحر المتوسط واع
اعتقد بان بث مثل هذه المعلومات الهدف
منها بان المقاومه اللبنانيه تعرف تماما
اهميه هذا الموقع وبالتالي وظيفتها لكن
ايضا في طيات قصف هذا الموقع تهديد واضح
وتحذير واضح ايضا لل للمسؤولين
الاسرائيليين وخصوصا وزير الدفاع
الاسرائيلي الذي قال قبل ايام بان يد
الجيش الاسرائيلي على الزناد الذي اريد
بحسب ما يمكن ان اقدره شخص شخصيا من خلال
استهداف هذا الموقع عدا او ناهيك عن عن
الرد على اغتيال الشهيد صالح العاروري
انما القول ايضا بان المقاومه اللبنانيه
لديها مجموعه اهداف استراتيجيه وحيويه
وبالتالي هذا جزء من اي عمليه تخض يخضع
لها بنك اهداف المقاومه في حال قررت سلطات
الاحتلال توسيع دائره عدوانها على لبنان
وبالتالي الذهاب الى حرب مفتوحه او شامله
معه او كما يقول الاسرائيليون بان النافذه
الدبلوماسيه اصبحت ضيقه ضيقه عفوا
وبالتالي فان الخيار العسكري اصبح اكثر
يعني اصبح اكثر اكثر سهوله بالنسبه لهم في
دقيقه ل تكرم السيد توفيق فيما يتعلق
بمهمه المسؤول الاوروبي السيد جوزيف بوريل
هل من ترشيحات او ترجيحات عما حمله السيد
بوريل في مهمته في
لبنان
لا الاثنان معا يعني في هناك ترشيحات وفي
ترجيحات ايضا لكن هو بصوره عامه قال بانه
جاء مستكشفا ومستطيل وبالتالي هو يحاول
لملمه بعض الافكار اللبنانيه وبالتالي
الاطلاع عليها عن كسب وبعد ذلك
جوجلتسجيل
الخارجيه اللبنانيه قوله بان المنطقه
بحاجه الى غير طبعا لم يشرح مثل هذا الامر
ولكن اعتقد بانه بمثل هذا التغيير هو
يتحدث عن ضروره حل سياسي
ودبلوماسي لكن كيف هذا غير معروف يعني
بحسب المعلومات التي يعني ايضا تتداول في
الاروقه المغلقه لم يتم يعني لم يقدم على
طرح افكار معينه ولكن كان جل اهتمامي بان
لا يجر لبنان كما قال حرفيا الى الاست
زازات الاسرائيليه وبالتالي تحويل الجبهه
اللبنانيه الى حرب مفتوحه مما قد يشعل
الجبهه الاقليميه برمتها تقريبا هذا هو
المضمون وهذا هو المحتوى مستطلع ومستكشف
وبالتالي محاولا ان ياخذ بعض ما يمكن ان
ياخذه من افكار لبنانيه في هذا المجال